China has massive influence within our
hemisphere
go to any island in the Caribbean the
American colonies there we call them
protectorates or Southern Colonies Saint
Croix Virgin Islands for example all the
infrastructure in San Carlos built by
China
what why would China be building the
airport
and the roads in Saint Croix and why are
they doing the same in Jamaica and Haiti
and virtually every population Center in
the Caribbean also true in South America
again
this is our hemisphere which for more
than 200 years we've said explicitly we
control we will not allow
you know world powers from across the
oceans to control you know anything of
meaning in our Hemisphere and yet they
are and this is being completely I never
heard anybody mention it
I've just noticed it from traveling a
lot so I would just start there and say
you know what is this about maybe it's
totally benign that they're building the
infrastructure in Bolivia
maybe it's not